Hãy lên thông báo đã kiế thuật thuận hợp tác với Camusia, nhằm chân nát gó hoàn động lừa đào chục tuyến,
đồng nghiệt là qua các tổng này diện thoại. Đây là cái quà của cuộc họp kéo sai hơn lời dơ,
dưới dưới chức khai nước, tập trung và các băng ngống tội phạm công nghệ hoạp đồng từ lãnh phủ Camusia
và lừa đào công dân thay lăng. Theo thuật thuật, Camusia sẽ mở chính sịch mở gió của trong hòm một tháng tới,
nhóm và cơ sở được thay lăng sắp định là điểm ngống lừa đào.
Chính quyền Camusia, Cam Cết, báo Camusia tài của họp quy băng đến dưới chung sắp tới.
Chúc khi đó, thay lăng sẽ theo sỏi hiệu quà của các biển phát ngày,
thông qua biển giám sát cái kêu nạn chực tuyến từ lãnh nhân.
Giờ phân tích châu sản, đồng thấy này không chỉ giúp giảm thiệu các vụ lừa đào suyên đến dưới,
mà còn tạo tên lệ hợp tác and điểm mạng, dưới hai cuu sai đồng nằm.